now can I just get a quick show of hands
how many of you have heard the phrase
the quadratic formula before hands up
straight right up okay how many of you
keep your hand up if you could actually
tell me what the quadratic formula is
okay no problem hands down what is the
quadratic formula well remember we've
had a look at these different kinds of
quadratic equations and we noticed that
depending on the numbers you get
sometimes you can use the simple method
of factorizing that's our first
technique you factorize but sometimes if
the numbers are a bit awkward you can't
think of factors like no one's going to
guess minus 3 minus root 5 so instead of
factorizing we complete the square right
so this is this second technique but
we're always mathematicians are always
searching for ways to make things easier
and completing this square is a long
process it has many steps you've got to
remember weird arbitrary stuff like
Harvard Square and that's quite tricky
so that's why what they did was
mathematicians sort a way to make this
process automatic ok and that's this
formula so this is a third and final
tool if you get a quadratic formula
sorry quadratic equation like this or
this or this you can use any of these
three approaches but you try and start
to use the simplest one try to use the
easiest tool if it doesn't work you can
try this if that doesn't work you can
try this so what is it if you have a
quadratic equation with any numbers for
a B and C and literally any numbers okay
then we can go straight to the solution
we can go straight to the last line if
we remember it's very long and awkward
formula so I'm going to quote it for you
okay it starts off like this minus B
there's a plus or minus in there just
like there's a plus or minus here the
square root of does anyone know b
squared minus 4ac all divided by 2a okay
now this object is monstrous okay you're
like holy cow
you're ten how am I supposed to remember
this thing now
the answer is just like every other
thing that you have memorized to do in
your life like say tying your shoelaces
or brushing your teeth or eventually
learning to drive you will learn this
object by using it okay so if you look
at it and you're intimidated it's fine
give yourself some time okay now I want
to do two things I'm gonna show you
things number one I want to show you how
to use it as it were I want to show you
how to drive it and then secondly I'm
gonna show you where it comes from but
one of the amazing things about this
formula is if you don't know where it
comes from
it still works just like your ever we're
talking about intrigue like you can know
how to drive a car without lifting the
hood and looking at the engine and
knowing how it does it stuff and that's
a really good thing for cars well this
is a pretty complicated car so if you
don't want to look under the hood that's
okay but I think some of you should so
I'm going to show that to you after I
show you how to use it so let's try it
and come up with an example okay in fact
I'm going to use an example from the
exercise let's have a look at this guy
okay so here's our example question now
this is a non monic quadratic do you
remember that non Mon acquire isn't it
Manik
what makes this not Manik yes this guy
here it's this coefficient it's not a
one unlike these guys which I just made
up and so you're like okay I'm gonna
have to use some fancy tools to do this
usually you're searching for a pair of
numbers what pair of numbers are you
searching for what do they add to adds
or two and what is the pair of numbers
multiply to negative six now if you
could think of a pair of numbers that
did that then you would factorize but I
can't so therefore I'm going to launch
into this if you have another color
there I'd like you to pick it up and
what we're gonna do is we're gonna label
out of this what are these numbers a B
and C okay how will look it's in the
right order
here's a it's three okay
here's B it's to just watch out C isn't
to see has this negative sign that comes
along for the ride so I'm just going to
run a little you draw a little curly
brace there C isn't - it's negative -
okay so now that I know what a B and C
are that's the hardest part of the
quadratic formula now I just poured in
him okay
x equals and I'm going to substitute all
the numbers in to the appropriate spots
okay you write ugly
sure I look forward to your attorney
okay one step at a time
- B that's minus two plus or minus
there's a big square root sign under
which I'm going to put some stuff B
squared is 2 squared take away 4 times a
which is 3 and negative 2 which is C I'm
gonna make my square root sign a bit
longer okay are you okay with that all
I've done is put the appropriate numbers
and substitute them into the appropriate
places that's times yeah so let me just
I haven't finished yet this is minus B
plus or minus the square root of there's
B squared minus 4 there's a and there's
C are you with me so far the last thing
I need to substitute is on the bottom 2a
which is 2 times 3 okay now before we
start to look at the next line you could
have done some of this simplification in
your head for example you guys know what
2 squared is and you know what 2 times 3
is particular this early stage where
we're trying to get a handle on the
formula I'm going to encourage you to do
it just like I've done here
don't do that shortcut and go 4 and 6
because number one we can do that in the
next line that's okay
number two the more things you're doing
your head the more places that you make
silly mistakes you know when you get a
payback you know like how do I make
these silly mistakes answer you try to
remember to do too many things at once
there's a lot of things to remember to
do here so let's just do that on its own
now let's simplify minus 2 plus or minus
this is four what's this can you
multiply all three of these numbers
together minus 4 and 3 and minus 2 yes
there's two negatives there's two
negatives so they're going to cancel out
which gives me a plus and then you go 4
times 3 times 2 is 12
times 2 which is 24 there you go that's
the thing under the square root
and then lastly I've got a 6 on the
bottom okay I can tidy this up just a
teeny bit more I've got minus 2 plus or
minus what's under the square root
28 that's divided by 6 ok now we're
pretty much done we're pretty much done
you can see all of the stuff that I
wrote down from the beginning I've
multiplied it all out I've collected
like terms however because you know a
thing or two about certs you can
actually write this a teeny teeny bit
simpler have a look just the third
square root of 28
are there any squares I can pull out of
this I can pull out the square root of 4
come on tight
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna say
the minus 2 is that the front when you
take out the square root of 4 well the
square root of 4 of course is hmm
what does it leave behind the square
root of 7 it's still there you'll see I
haven't I haven't dealt with that yet
okay now I have a look at this having
simplified this surd can I do any more
to make it better
look carefully have a look at the
fraction have a look at the whole
fraction there's a common factor on the
top and the bottom isn't there the this
is even and this is also even so I'm
going to divide everything by 2 okay
oh yeah man not much but there you go
Thanks let's divide everything by 2
what is the negative to become negative
1 plus or minus what does this become
when you divided by 2 just root 7
thanks man and then on the bottom and
now you're finished ok so
this doesn't make things like oh well
it's so easy okay it's still a fair bit
of work you've got to know about certs
you've got to do a lot of very careful
substitution however I guess what I
would point out is you know when you are
completing the square
you know you complete the square you had
to think really hard about each step of
the process you're like wait what do I
do next
oh it's had having and squaring thing oh
okay I need this kind of number right
the quadratic formula once you've
written down the first slide it kind of
just unfolds I know it's a word I don't
like very much but all you have to do is
simplify okay you start with something
that's a horrendous mess and they you
just have to simplify as far as you
possibly can
okay okay so in summary right now that
you've got three tools the important
thing is well how do I know which one to
use okay have a look at the quadratic
and you go in this order if you haven't
written this down and encourage you to
do that they've put a big box around it
these are your methods for solving
quadratics I'll leave a time with their
methods for solving quadratics the very
first thing you do is you try and
factorize always try and factorize it is
by far the fastest way to go if you can
think of that pair of numbers then
you're good okay but in many many cases
right we've just we've held you we
haven't shown you those cases because
you didn't have these tools before but
now that you know them in many cases you
can't factorize you can't think of that
pair of numbers who's gonna think of
these right oh yeah that's these are my
favorite numbers okay you're not gonna
think of them to factorize so then you
have a choice you can either complete
the square sometimes the question will
tell you by completing the square solve
or you can launch into this formula just
like we have okay so in a real way these
two options are kind of equivalent okay
in a few minutes I'm gonna show you why
they're equivalent but you can use
either of them